here at Jiffy Pop hey champ  you got a good run oh sorry your racing  days are coming to an end in cars three  Lightning McQueen has to prove he can  keep up with a new generation of racers  all eyes at me tells the story of Tupac  from his early days as a rapper to his  rise of the poet and actor and a  cultural icon  body cameras although me why me because  I'm too [ __ ] this weekend's all about  us just like old times  Scarlett Johansson stars in rough night  a raunchy comedy about a bachelorette  party gone horribly wrong everything  away see what's hot in theaters with  this week spent to the patients  [Music]  and so what's your weekend to get going  to be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]